e
we could just are we being recorded
today
okay okay all right so U I'm calling
this meeting to order um to the
committee to study the impact of the
housing crisis on people with
disabilities if we could just go on and
introduce ourselves why don't you start
hello uh my name is representative yella
I am uh representing Rockingham District
32 in those are the towns of Fremont
brenwood representative jusica lontine
of Dober New Hampshire and straford
17 Senator good afternoon everyone I'm
Denise Rashard the state senator for
District 9 which represents 13 towns
from Bedford to hin
it's good to see you all here today for
such an important issue hi I'm I am
representative Kathy stab I represent W
five in Manchester which is Hillsboro
District 25 and I am the chair of this
committee and so why don't we begin um
by looking at the minutes from the
previous meeting and approving those
thank you uh Jessica for doing such a
thorough job I think they're fabulous um
I I did look at them ear earlier and I
do have one
correction um Alysa
um from yes Alyssa margine her her name
is spelled e l i
SSA okay she's not an a Alysa she's an
sorry okay thank you thank you okay
all
right
did
you Lori McIntosh came forward and
issued an apology statements about that
her comments about that money that you
had found for
public
abstain i d i
okay here we go so three of us approve
and one AB
abstention okay all right
um oh you know our our our task today is
to um look at what we want to include in
the um in the preliminary report there
is um we are required to produce a
preliminary report by November 1st which
which is in a couple of days um the
committee has been authorized to
continue into the next bium for another
year at which point the committee will
issue a a final
report um so um I put together some
thoughts and um I put them into a Word
document and printed it all up for you
and forgot them on my printer at home
and realized that that when I was
halfway here so um our researcher is in
the process of copying them and there
she is so you can you'll have something
to um you know to work off of as we are
report thank
you isn't there another member of the
committee yes that that um yes that
representative Welsh is in theory on the
committee so I guess his name probably
should be on the report shouldn't it
no yeah that's why you know that's why
report I just did this from the second
page there is a cover page also that I
think we were emailed last week
um it says the names of the people to
okay so I I I had another thing that I
noticed um Kristen on the first page of
that report is that it lists the state
Librarian Is Michael York and I believe
I believe he has retired he's he's
city right or if there's an
interim okay all right thank you okay
um yeah before we go to the the finding
section of it
um um the committee charge and study
purpose um number two says that the
committee shall solicit information and
there's a long list of PE of
organizations that we were supposed to
have
um spoken with and we did speak with a
lot of them but
um there there are some that we
missed so the actual law as
written had a list of organizations that
we were supposed to meet with and um
receive testimony from and we got most
of them but we did not get all of them
so I think one of the recommendations
should be that we follow up with um
individuals and organizations mentioned
in the law that um were unable to
testify before us are you okay with that
um you not all of them it seemed to say
that you you you
were saying that not all of them came to
testify but in the law it just requires
that we solicit them so did we reach out
to all of
them and maybe some of them didn't
respond I believe that there were some
that I did not get to reach out to okay
because I was unable to find contact
information for them or I just was
um whatever the reason disorganized
there were you know like um like uh
Southern New Hampshire Services I did
not reach out to them we did you know we
did hear from the community support
network which is you know an an an
umbrella Organization for
the
providers um but I think you
know that one of our recommendations can
be to make certain that we reach out to
individuals who were not
um contacted or who who were not able to
provide provide testimony during that
so that's good it covers your the bases
of the report and the
law um did you happen to see the email
that I sent a little while ago to you
yes I did okay okay so and I think that
on the first on the first recommendation
which is you know try to deal with the
distinct the distinction between
certification and lure
that's um your your thoughts seem to be
related to figuring out how to get
around that threers thing so why don't
you go ahead and explain what you said
to me so what I was um so I sent kind of
like some draft thoughts to the the
chair earlier today um
and what I one of the things the first
thing that was listed um on my draft
like one of the things that I was
thinking about was um the definition of
facility but um I looked at um
e- m1001 certification standards for
development to services and Community
residences and they didn't specifically
Define facility but they defined
Community
residence which means either agency
residence or a family residence
exclusive of independent living
arrangements so family
resident um
is
defined um in the same section saying
Family Residence means a community
residence essential uh
operated a a specific way and so those
are circular definitions one refers to
the other and I think that actually a
family res um a family
residence
uh we could
potentially uh discuss with
DHHS changing
that circular reference back to um say a
family residence means a residential
unit um instead of uh Community
residents and so residential units
generally like if you have an apartment
it has multiple residential units and so
you can have Apartment A and Apartment B
and those would be two separate
facilities even though they're in the
same building possibly and so you know
if if you have two children that are are
uh developmentally disabled or whatever
and receiving services and then a person
in the same building that's not even
related to you you don't know them like
they also have two people that are also
receiving services that you're somehow
not required now to be licensed in some
way um and so maybe discussing that uh
kind of language change might uh address
some of the the concerns that I have
especially for the low hanging fruit
like that um that I'm that I'm thinking
about maybe um we could Define
residential unit within this area like I
just pulled off a uh something off
online that said housing unit is a
single unit within a larger structure
that can be used in individual household
to sleep eat and live and so if you know
if you have a lease or whatever for that
apartment then that's kind of could be
your your residential uh what is it
called residential family residents and
I think that's what they were trying to
get at um and not um kind of classifying
the entire structure and so I think that
working with them on that because it's
technically in a rules so it's not
necessarily a law
change um that would be required it
might just have to go to the rules
committee or something to get uh a
language change uh to see if that is
possible to be changed
uh I think that was is something that
that was the first thing that I
thought um just so everyone on the on
the committee knows I I'll go down to
the second one I think that we should be
recommending legislation that allows
sorry that allows um I what I heard from
the testimony is that people uh with
disabilities often that may not even be
receiving Services May rely on The
Neighbor Next Door or the or the person
in the apartment across from them to be
helping them with rare needs but with
needs that they have that if they didn't
have that person that resource may not
be able to be independent and may have
to be in a more structured kind of like
living environment so encouraging um
duplexes triplexes quadruplexes a and um
and
adus where the people are relatively
close together um should be something
that is seen as as uh helping those that
are not not disabled enough to need to
go to like round the-clock care but may
need you know help bringing out the
garbage or or bringing up um you know uh
groceries or something that is you know
uh a rare occurrence but
but maybe need may be needed nonetheless
that can be seen as something that that
could be a barrier to them and then next
I thought that um we we heard that kind
of not not all of the people with
disabilities
drive and also spent find it expensive
or hard to come by the um
transportation and so having uh the
ability
to either have um within commercial
districts mixed use uh buildings that
have residential and and businesses in
the same building so that they could you
know go downstairs to the grocery store
or to the coffee shop or whatever and
wouldn't have to travel for every single
thing in their life that might be a a
beneficial uh opportunity for some that
that need that and or walking walk being
able to walk or and or roll if necessary
to the uh to a business next door or
something like that so if they had a
sidewalk or something like that that may
also help those people that are um not
able and you know not even just people
that are disabled people that can't
drive um for whatever reason even if
they're not disabled um you know got in
trouble with the law or whatever too too
many DUIs like that's that that could be
some um a a situation that would be
helpful for those people not just the
disabled communities so I think that um
is something that the state should kind
of encourage if not say like hey if you
you know you're you need to
be not kind of forcing everyone into
just Manchester and NASA that but we
want people to be able to live in their
own communities and so you need to have
some place in your community that can be
able to meet these these guidelines um
the next thing I was talking about was
New Hampshire Housing Authority um may
or may not be able to use its loans that
it provides um for the creation of
community
resides under uh the
hm11 uh so I wanted to make sure that
that if the legislature needs to say
like hey they can can get this loan if
they want to purchase this property and
and provide services there that that
they would be able to take advantage of
that because we are like one of the
thing that it is we are trying to do is
to be able to allow multif family
housing or or or low uh or just uh
affordable housing options and so
um if like just having more um
opportunities for these disabled people
could bring the cost cost cost down um
for them and not just uh you know for
everyone else cons and then um then my
last thing was kind of concern in
general that I that the testimony that
that we are studying um how how the
impact of housing crisis
affected people with disabilities and a
lot of the testimony had to do with
developmental disabilities and not so
much about physical disabilities and I
had a little concern that that we may be
a want to be soliciting
some some testimony specifically from
people that um have physical disability
so that we make sure that we're kind of
being
like addressing the entire
Community all right those are those are
the things that I came up off top of my
head thank you so much for doing that
um okay all right so
um can let
um let me just um go through the
findings that I put down and see if
there's anything that we want add um the
first finding that I had was the
certification versus lure distinction is
a barrier to developing new housing for
people with developmental disabilities
it adds significant cost to construction
maintenance and management of these
types of developments and I think that
that's one of the things that um you
were talking about with the um change in
that definition so um do we all agree
that that um
is something that we uncovered during
this um um process and um are there
changes that you think we should make to
the wording there
um do you think it needs to be more
specific or is
that I agree with you we heard a lot
from um the people in the community that
there's too much confusion on these
definitions and there's no one place for
anyone to go and actually get help I
think we should take those suggestions
that were given to us um try to and work
with the department so that we can
remove any objections and then we could
maybe make that change and that would be
a good stepping stone to um what what
else we have to do
right right and we may uncover other in
the process we may uncover other things
that we might be able to do through Ru
making or legislation that will make it
easy easier for um individuals or groups
that want to build housing for people
with developmental
disabilities okay all right the the next
finding um and this was specifically
from Gia the grand State Independent
Living folks um there is a severe
shortage of units in the state to
accommodate people with physical
disabilities less than 5% of housing
units are considered accessible and less
than 1% are wheelchair share accessible
and retrofitting existing buildings is
difficult and expensive so that was
something that we heard from um Grand
living and you
know is
that do we agree that that was a finding
differently go ahead yeah I I
didn't take away I maybe from from them
but other people um that I don't believe
a that that the state should be
essentially saying that every house you
know needs to to have this certain kind
of structure like that you have to build
the bedrooms on the first floor whatever
the bathroom has to be curbless or
something like that like that feel like
those I think those are individual
design choices within you know family
residences um and it's good to know like
the being able to how the difficulty of
moving in between locations for a person
with disability but I don't think that
the uh the
intention should necessarily be that
that we have to do 100% you know
Universal Design on every building in
the state kind of a thing I don't think
that that is something
that it can be brought up as maybe like
encouragements um but I don't think that
it at least that's what a feeling I got
from the testimony that it shouldn't be
mandated that we that everyone do a
Universal Design or something like that
right okay representative lontine and
then represent and then uh senator
richardi
yeah I agree with some of that but I
think what we wanted to do um was first
identify the problems that we found and
then we say move on to recommendations
unless you want to deal with each of
those finding and recommendations one at
a time what do you want it do you know
what I'm
saying yeah okay like we were doing them
or we just say for each we'll discuss
what we found and then discuss the
recommendation for each one one of a
time okay all right well Senator Richard
yeah I was thinking the same thing we
have we probably should be identifying
first if there's something we can do
this upcoming session legislatively like
maybe fix the rules I think we should
tackle that and and nudge things forward
but identifying a lot of these problems
the solution is not uh quick and we're
gonna have to try to find the these
Solutions right right well um it I I
think um uh representative lon's uh
point is well taken um one thing that I
did put in recommendations directly in
response to that was um to investigate
whether existing Housing Programs such
as the New Hampshire Housing Trust or
the 79e program can be used to
incentivize Builders to include
Universal Design in new construction
projects because um you know and we were
we had asked the folks from New
Hampshire housing to give us some um um
some information on what the
differential and cost would be um
between just building a a unit and
building one that was um um built to be
accessible so that that was just you
know what what I something that I
thought we could look into as as an
mandate agree with that I mean did you
get get the response back because I'm I
I heard that there was there was um
concern that retrofitting existing
buildings is difficult and expensive
obviously um maybe to Universal Design
that would be but maybe if
someone just needed you know a curb
shower or something it wouldn't
necessarily be
um prohibitively expensive you know if
you needed to widen the the the the
hallways or something maybe that would
be
but um and so I didn't I don't remember
seeing uh the the answer of how how uh
expensive it was um in
general so I'm not sure that I
can L go ahead as someone that does um a
lot of bath remodeling work it would add
a lot of money I mean the cheapest
bathroom you could build is just buy a a
curbed shower stall and installing it
and then doing anything custom to make
it
accessible is a lot more money like 50
to 100% more but that doesn't
mean um I mean my thoughts on this
subject is that
any
um new uh multifamily project needs to
make a certain percent of those units um
with universal divine
design even if it's
retrofitting uh a 3un um apartment
building do a whole remodel it make you
know one of them has to be accessible
but I I agree that mandating that every
new unit be built to Universal Design
would put would increase the cost of
housing tremendously and therefore we're
we're causing a lot of other problems
for people who need housing we we need
more
resources
Senator I'm just thinking out loud so
this may not be a good idea but um a
couple sessions ago I worked with the
New Hampshire Housing Authority and Ben
Frost to do a p a pilot
program was for to make things
affordable so the American dream is to
own your own home and that really hasn't
changed it's just not affordable it's
not affordable for families with
disabilities it's not affordable for
single people young families but they
want that even if it's small and and
Tiny and in a community and so I it took
a lot of traction and I got the bill
very far but then it ultimately uh died
and I'm just wondering to address the
fact of choice where some families with
disabilities want to live in in
communities with all people I'm
wondering if I reintroduce this pilot as
a good test see what if it passes what
kind of progress and it will include all
people but it's but a priority for
families with
disabilities and um these are actually
made I got the idea from Maine and
they're actually made out of
um like a concrete but they're beautiful
um with 3D printing and I it's really
amazing it would be affordable for the
state dep partner in this because I
already got them to agree to do it as a
pilot in general it just didn't get all
the way through the process so again I'm
thinking out loud but it would be a test
and it would fulfill uh AB broad
families with disabilities like this
committee has been tasked with but it'll
also help with anyone else you'll have
to qualify there'll be a process um and
I just again I apologize I'm just
thinking out loud as something that we
could maybe try legislatively for now in
conjunction with making it easier with
the rule change and I've been talking to
the um New Hampshire Builders
Association um in trying to work with me
and work with um the uh with Ben Frost
and so I'm going down the path of giving
that a whirl I just want to know if
there's any support support for that
room let me I I think that's a cool idea
and I think that where you're looking at
um everything being 3D
printed then it would just be a matter
of the design being different um in
order to be accommodating because you
you know you're not you won't you
wouldn't be dealing with wood or what
you'd be dealing with a plastic sub
substance that could be
include ramps wider doorways Etc but you
know I don't really know enough about uh
I'm just speculating that that's how
that works because I haven't really done
it but um yeah that's that seems like an
interesting idea yeah I I would
co-sponsor that with you okay okay
um I'm not sure that I understood what
the the pilot program was exactly
because I mean I've seen the 3D printing
of houses before um are you are you
suggesting that the pilot program was so
that some 3D printed houses are done in
New Hampshire or the pilot program was
like subsidizing like the the uh the
loan of of it or how how what was the
exact nature of the pil it needs to be
worked out a little bit better but it
was was a a combination of all the above
the reason it didn't get through is in
finance um we had the housing Champion
Bill and it was just too much money so
they mine got swept away but I think it
could be Revisited and the details
worked out um but this time we could
have the
focus on all affordable but making sure
there's a priority for families with
disabilities I don't know how I'm going
to do that or if I should but I think
there's potential
there I just have to work with the
knowledge representative lonte you have
the most building experience of anyone
here do you know what do you know about
3D printed
houses I don't know anything about them
but my first thought is like where do
you get all the plastic to feed into
that printer I mean PL it's it's not
plastic it's concrete oh okay I I have
seen a little bit they have a big it's
like a nozzle that goes around and
prints the walls and then you can have
it like plastered or whatever so that
it's instead of having like The Ridges
it it's all looks like flat but it's
it's totally awesome but there's there's
multiple ways that you can get I imagine
you would still need a lot of um finish
work and other surfaces that
involve labor and materials to make it
so you're not just living in a concrete
cell I mean you still need electrical
wiring and plumbing I mean I don't know
that it would be a huge cost savings but
it's yeah so it seems like it's quite a
few years down the road before that's
yeah well you know they are doing it in
Main and and I I the thing with the
plumbing and the um and the electrical
most of that would be the same for uh
whether you were building the house for
able-bodied people or or or with um a
family that had someone with a
disability I think again the additional
expense would go toward you know things
like bathroom fixtures Etc that you're
not going to make out of poured concrete
yeah that be
scratchy senator they look nice I mean
if you see how nice you'd never know
they're just they're small but that's
okay
yeah we have to think a little bit out
of the box that all ideas may not be
good ones including my own but I want to
try to move the needle you know we have
to take bites of the Apple um there
isn't going to be any one solution I
mean maybe we can see if the state can
put in something that would give us more
f Federal matching dollars I you know
that may be a possibility too but we we
have to discuss all the ideas to find
the
solutions
yeah okay any other thoughts on uh
Universal designs before we go to the
next
finding okay um the the next um finding
was that um people who receive their
income from Social Security Disability
or supplemental security income do not
make enough money to rent market rate
Apartments the waiting list for housing
Choice vouchers in New Hampshire is 6
to8 years currently 6,300 elderly or
disabled people in New Hampshire hold
vouchers and another 12,000 people are
on the waiting
list um so you know we did we did hear
from some people who were um
um develop disabilities later in life
who were unable to find apartments that
they could afford because they were no
longer able to work and were on
disability and had applied for housing
Choice vouchers and were not able to
secure them and we also heard from New
Hampshire housing um Finance Authority
um
that they there aren't enough of them to
go around um so do we have any thoughts
on um what how we might be able to
um look into that I
[Music]
mean um one person s suggested that the
state would be able to put money into
the um into the voucher account and they
said in Massachusetts they were doing
some of that um or you know
creating creating you there two kinds of
units there's the one that's transver
that goes to the individ individual and
then they have to find an apartment and
then there are the other ones that where
the subsidy is tied to the individual
unit so you build an apartment building
elderly housing or whatever and each one
of those units for the people who live
there they only need to pay onethird of
their income and then the rest of it is
paid by a federal um a voucher rent
voucher I would say the the first
problem is that those Social Security
checks are not high enough and maybe we
make a strong recommendation to our
federal delegation that they work on
increasing that along with overhaul of
the whole funding mechanism that the cap
on
contributions to Social Security is
still capped at like 150
$130,000 a year and after that you don't
contribute more of your income so that
needs to be lifted
so first of
all more money into Social
Security but I got the impression from
um who was it
um Alyssa that she thought trying to get
increases in vouchers for HUD is not
going to
happen um and
that um a
better thing would be increasing the um
state of um through the real estate
transfer tax increasing the funds that
go into the state um affordable housing
fund so that maybe the state can help
directly Finance some new projects that
disabilities all right Senator I just I
want to bring up another um problem so
that we will be able to figure out
something um we heard a lot of testimony
from people who needed procedures in the
hospital
and
they the hospital can't let them go home
if they don't have a home to go to or
they um are not able to be fit at home
and that's keeping beds from being from
other people who need to be in the
hospital so that is another problem that
we're going to have to look at they they
just can't release somebody when they
have nowhere to
go yeah some of them end up in shelters
in
Manchester with because they have no
home to go to so we have we have people
that are brought directly from the
so yeah I
I yeah I I agree that that that that is
um but as far as
um specifically that you know that
people can't afford the market rate
Apartments
um I mean one thing would be if there is
a large project going in anywhere that
um we can't really mandate
that it's the towns and cities that
approve those projects um but we could
perhaps recommend or may maybe it is a
state
um we we
could move toward requiring a certain
percent be set aside for
um that are affordable I we're talking
there's so much money going into housing
in this state the tremendous amount of
money I I don't if we can't use some of
those resources we're really in trouble
I don't think man you know I like local
control I don't think you can mandate
but I think you can
incentivize um and I don't think that
works out too well when you start
mandating things I I think we have to
find a better a better way to
incentivize um maybe in a in a tax
credit or something like that rather
than more taxing um tax
credit if if I may I I I do think that
there are um you know like there are
programs where people get you know
Federal guaranteed loans or they get tax
credits from communities Etc and I don't
think there's anything in law that would
allow a city or town to say yes we will
give you this variance yes we will give
you this um you know this fiveyear tax
abatement but only if you include some
affordable units in this you know know
50 unit apartment building there's I
don't think that that that by law you
can can do that
so
they yeah they have there's some way
that it gets done in Manchester they
tell us it's impossible because it's it
would be
illegal but in do they've been doing it
I agree that it's illegal whether or not
that Dober is doing it that's a question
for the courts that
um I definitely am
not in favor of of suggesting changes to
to Social Security um however I do think
that the
um that the New Hampshire Housing
Authority uh five I think it's only $5
million that if we want to see more
projects being done then
then yeah
increasing that amount of money from the
real estate transfer tax makes more
sense cuz more money means more projects
are going to be able to be
um you know money is going to be able to
be lent out for
that um and so I think that's definitely
something that should look into um
definitely in the next budget budget
yeah and and you know I think that that
that is really a good idea and I I think
um but I I I still
feel like maybe providing some kind of a
bonus from that money to um developers
who are willing to put in a unit or two
of um Universal Design housing in in a
large project you know as an incentive
um not as a
mandate I definitely liked like yes that
idea as far as
the if there was some
if we had some number of like you know
it's 10% or 15% more um added to the
project if the state wanted to earmark
some some you know money and say like
hey we want you to do a program or a
pilot program for a couple of years
where we're going to you know give you
25% or whatever if you do a certain
amount of the units or maybe we we put
you higher up on the list or whatever
like you more points as far as you're
you know they're trying to get points or
whatever to get get higher in the
funding that maybe one of those
categories for points could be the
number of units with Universal Design or
something like that that's great that's
a great idea yeah because um because
when we heard from New Hampshire Housing
Finance they did say that um all of
their um they they have a competitive
process and it is based on points so you
know adding
um you know for for projects that you
know come out of the affordable housing
um
fund you
know I and I I don't even
know I'm so so sad you're not going to
be here um I I wouldn't even know like
how to where where would that lever be
would it be would it be legislative to
say that do do we get to say how how the
points are awarded in the um affordable
housing trust uh
process or is that something we would
need to do more research on are you
saying is that mandated at the federal
level and we can't control it because
it's t funding it's definit no the New
Hampshire Housing Authority is is
funded
um through the real estate well the the
$5 million that we're talking about
loaning out um and
is comes from our New Hampshire real
estate transfer tax a certain amount of
money of that goes to that fund and then
the rest goes to our general fund and so
that's New Hampshire's money and so
there the strings are our strings that
we put on um so I think that it that
those rules for New Hampshire housing
are probably in rules and would are
impact of them can be legislative but
generally it's going to be through the
rule set setting committee okay um and
so I think that working with New
Hampshire housing to say like hey we
were thinking that this would be
good gauge their interests gauge their
like is there some hurdles towards that
and then reaching out to the people on
the uh uh the uh rule setting committee
and say hey we want we want to implement
this how to how do we achieve that I
think is the next steps for that yeah
but I mean I think most of the money
from the New Hampshire Housing Authority
comes from federal funds that $5 million
is hardly going to build one apartment
building um that's correct but if if it
was a yeah so if there you know if there
is a project that's getting money from a
a you know a bunch of different
buckets um as an incentive you
know to get the get some of the money
from the New Hampshire Housing Trust
because it you know that $5 million as
you said would not go very far for one
project but as a um you know as were
able to get more money put into that
fund then
um then we would have you know more that
we could uh put toward
building
yeah housing for people with
disabilities
so I I think another concern that I
heard um in our hearings is that there
are a lot of buildings that were built
um for 30-year plans to provide so many
units that are affordable or accept that
accept vouchers and those are about to
expire like a lot of them so there going
to be in even more shortage so but
probably these buildings after 30 years
are going to need major Renovations and
they'll be looking for new
Capital to do that and if we
can
um also incentivize that they continue
to to accept vouchers if they want any
funding to do
that um rather than have them all
and you know I I I still think it would
be a good idea to reach out to the
members of the federal um delegation I
mean there
um you know increasing the amounts we
you know we but but also specific
specifically related to housing and
there's a couple of things like the the
fair claw Amendment which forbids
construction of new like housing
projects um that are owned by the local
Housing Authority
like when in you know in Manchester we
have things like the uh Elmwood Gardens
and the rock rimen project Etc and um
they're
um they're not allowed to build that
kind of project anymore because of the
fair claw Amendment because they moved
away from doing that specifically in
building uh affordable housing to the
voucher system where they could um put
th those funds into the private
sector so I you know I I still think
that it would be worth talking to them
and uh seeing if there's because there
you know and the other thing is that we
think we can change the rules here in um
New Hampshire so that we can allow for
more flexibility in housing people with
disabilities but HUD may think otherwise
and I think having the federal
delegation on our side um to maybe
um advocate for um our people um in New
Hampshire um might be worth doing
um just because it's it's a it's a
potential barrier to doing what we're
hoping to do go ahead if we if you were
to say something like we recommend to
the federal delegation that they work
with HUD to allow more flexibility in
the administration of the
um from our local housing authority to
suit the needs of our state more
particularly then I think
that's that
um is definitely you know and and also
doing um just
whatever whatever that they can do at
the federal level obviously they're
they're working at a different you know
different projects but anything that
that could possibly bring more
options um for housing to people in
general and people specifically with
disabilities than that that would be a
help because it's not it's not something
that the the the state is going to be
able to
completely uh you know solve on its own
we're going to need you know individuals
Building
Homes municipalities getting out of the
way so that they can build homes um you
know people at the H you know the
federal issue also but it's it's at all
levels and and um the biggest impact
that we have is obviously on the state
level but we need those other people to
partner with us I guess in solving the
the
issue well in and I put down additional
housing vouchers which doesn't seem to
be like we have an appetite for that but
how about just additional resources
because that could be
a variety of
things
right okay all right
um the the last thing that we heard
about last week was um a New Hampshire
Medicaid housing benefit um program
that was signed into law in 2022 and has
yet to be
implemented that was what Alyssa was
talking about that um there had been um
a law that was passed in the budget and
um and and it has hasn't been
implemented yet so it was signed in 2022
so I want to look into that I think
that's a recommendation to look into
that um law and why um what what's a
hold up
Y is everyone because you know that that
that's for um Supportive Housing and um
that would be that would be a huge
um a huge Boon to the people who are you
know trying to provide Supportive
people okay the last thing that I have
on here that we learned about was the
state's stable savings program that
allows people who receive benefits to
save money without losing benefits and
that this is a resource that can be used
to pay for housing whether rented or
purchased
um does anyone have any recommendations
about what we can do with that knowledge
to help move
the move the process of finding safe
affordable and appropriate housing for
people with disabil
abilities I for me um I've been thinking
that about that a little bit um like my
my
stepdaughter who has Down
syndrome um and has been in a very
stable um Home Care providership
administered um by one of the area
agencies and you know has um Medicare so
her housing and her health care are
taken care of and also the housing
includes most of her
food since um the pandemic she has been
making more money in her part-time job
and she is actually saving
money which is
great though um as a family we sort of
save that money for her okay could be in
a sable account but there are a lot of
people
who on are on disability that became
disabled later they weren't born with
the disability they became disabled that
aren't eligible for that and also as we
heard from several
people they just barely make ends eat
it's not possible meat it's not possible
for them to save money period when they
can barely pay for their housing and
their
food as it is there's nothing left over
so I don't know
how expanding this prr program would
help that population who are the ones Mo
really struggling right
now yeah well one of the things that um
that um they did say was that the
um you know people who have set up
trusts for um their disabled children um
can transfer that money from the trust
to this stable account and then have it
and use it for use it for
housing so it's you know kind of a stop
Gap in between and I you know but if if
like in in Eliza's case she doesn't need
the money for housing the money for
housing comes from um you know all over
social security goes to the state
agency and they have they use other
resources
um and I don't fully understand it I you
know I don't think it's a Medicare
waiver Medicaid waiver but
possibly so and what I'm saying is she
doesn't need a stable account to pay for
her housing that's taken care of it can
so
um it's not benefiting a certain
population that needs the money to pay
for rent like many of the people um that
we heard testimony
about that were struggling to pay rent
with their fairly recent onset
disability would not be eligible for
this anyway and they wouldn't have any
extra money to put into it well I I
think if I may one of the um one of the
concerns that we've heard an awful lot
from parents of adults with disability
is what happens to their children after
after they're gone you know they're
living at home with their parents so um
in that case there wouldn't be anybody
to manage that money for them I mean you
the family if the family was no longer
there to manage the money and hold the
account for that person like when I hate
to say this but when you and your
husband are gone you know who who's
going to manage Eliza's account will she
be able to have a savings account with
any more than $2,000 in it if she wants
to you know buy stuff well you set it up
and you know a like like with Social
Security you have a rep pay that manages
account and then she would have someone
else like her sister but the idea of
having Eliza in a St stable home care
providership you hope that the area
agency will continue to look out for her
interest she will continue to have an
independent case manager looking out for
her
interest but like the stable program can
have the advantage of other family
members contributing to it if As Long As
I understood that
correctly um but again there will be a
lot of people that don't have the family
support that are going to contribute
independently to their stable account to
out all right so well
there was one other suggestion I heard a
few times um is that there needs to be
someone at the
state either in um The Bureau Bureau of
Developmental Disabilities or somewhere
else at
DHHS whose specific job it is to help
these families that are trying to set up
new housing
um facilities
that they these families have felt
they're all on their own trying to
figure it out they don't know who to
call and you know to sort of set up one
person and and hopefully you could do it
without having to create a new
position but say to um Health and Human
Services or
BDS let's appoint someone whose job it
is that's going to help um families that
are trying to create new housing Sy
situations to redefine the job
definition and then make that clearly
known across the community that they're
help Senator I think in the uh you've
covered this very well by the way thank
you for doing that for the preliminary
report and I just think we should also
put in there that we need to sit down um
not individually but we have to have the
New Hampshire builders
the
developers the uh invest New Hampshire
um the medical uh Hospital Association
director and we should have them all at
once and oh and the real estate people
because all this impacts everybody and
try to get everybody coming together for
a solution where everybody's on
board um so that we're not trying to do
one thing and then then you get this
other entity that objects and then we
spin our Wheels I think if we can give
everybody a seat at the table that we
could probably come up with something
that's
doable and that might be a good addition
to the report because it shows what
we're trying to do going
forward all right so so are you looking
at possibly creating a commission
commiss that sounds like a commission it
does I
just I'm just trying to think about the
best way to move
forward yeah I well I'm I'm I'm open to
making the recommendation that you know
we appoint a commission um I don't know
how to move forward without having all
these people have a seat at the table
but maybe someone else has an idea but
they all need to be part of this process
yeah is there a a commission to look at
generally other than the special
committee that we
have the
legislature I don't believe so he
representative yella is on that study
committee or that committee
no I don't believe that there is a
commission specifically about
housing
um as far as I know I don't think I
don't know that there is I I I wonder if
like in
the maybe in
the
um you know resource business and
resources or Department that the state
has if they've got people that are
looking at the housing situation because
that the lack of housing has had such a
significant impact on the ability to
attract and r workers and and build
businesses so I'm wondering if there's
something in there but again you know
this is a
the the
um the agenda you know would be
different than it would be um where
you're looking at people with
disabilities ities and significant you
know health issues
and needs that are um you know um needs
for support that they they probably
wouldn't even think about so I you know
I'm I'm I'm open to putting that
recommendation in there no you know
there's no saying
that just because we put it in our
recommendations it doesn't mean it's
going to happen right that's right but
if we don't have all those people on
board to come to the table I don't know
how we can have the most impactful
solution yeah I I agree I think it seems
like a good idea um
does I mean I think that in some sense
you know a special committee on housing
creates a a study committee that then
creates a commission like I feel like
that some point there's there we're kind
of like chasing our tail but yes I get
I'm not opposed to it I just I just
think that it's
um it could have been like you know
those Representatives could have been on
on the study committee right it it could
have been um like would they have to
start all over again and listen to all
of the same testimony all over again to
just to to get back up to speed of where
or are you saying like here's a
commission on a specific Focus that we
have identified based on listening to
all of the testimony we want to you know
fix uh a commission on on the you know a
two-year commission or a four-year
Commission on on fixing the the the
impact of uh The Lure and certification
process and get those stakeholders that
are trying to create them and DHHS and
and legislatur is all in the same room
and say we're going to fix this problem
and make it easier for you to create
housing for these people right or um or
are you just going to be like okay I
want I want you guys all in a room and I
want you to fix housing for disabled
people and that that's essentially the
same as this committee right well my
thought was that we we have subsequent
meetings that we invite them and ask
them to come so that we can pick their
brains and
get them on board with suggestions that
doesn't that the real estate people or
the new Hing Hampshire Authority or the
developers don't object when we actually
make legislation that they got a seat at
the table I wasn't thinking of another
committee but inviting them where they
can come multiple times to be a part of
this so that they're not negatively
impacted but want to find Solutions over
the next year what what about a a a bill
to uh add them to this committee
yeah I yeah I think like I think that
that might be the a good idea well I
think it's a good idea but I think the
reason that you know we're um you know
as as as a rookie legislator and as
someone who um has never done this
before um the the rules and the
requirements for a legislatively
appointed study committee limit the you
know the level of of uh conversation
that can take place and and I recall a
couple of weeks ago when um they were
here from the New Hampshire Housing
Finance Authority that they um sought
out the opportunity to have offline
conversations about some of the issues
that we brought up with them so I'm um I
I don't think that I don't know that in
this structure that we can have that
kind of back and forth that um you would
like to um that you think well and and I
believe are are necessary in order to
move the process forward so you know I
think going forward what I was looking
at is having the conversations you know
going to DH HS or BDS and sitting down
with them and saying okay what do you
think and then maybe talking to somebody
in HUD and you know just trying to focus
in on these uh little things but um you
know these individual issues and
problems but yeah I agree with you that
you know this the
whole it's it's a it's a big problem
with a lot of moving parts
that not including people could create
unintended consequences and I think
that's what we need to avoid that's what
I was yes trying to get at is that so
and and I don't know commissions operate
I've never been on one oh I was on one
before I was even in in the legislature
I was appointed by the governor um
so uh and it there's people from all
different backgrounds that come and then
you meet it was during covid so we were
zooming but um and then same thing you
do your reports and recommendations are
made and then legislation came out of
it and it was year long yeah but I just
feel we need more of those
experts and we want them to all be on
board and on the same
page I'm just thinking out loud because
this is the time that we can you know
well you know one thing that we can do
and putting forward our recommendation
is to say that we need to hear from more
of the stakeholders and then you know
list the ones that you have mentioned
about um how you know we want to um we
want to engage with them and not
necessarily figure out um you know it
might not be in this environment it
might be some I and and I you know
Freedom of Information laws and all that
kind of stuff I don't know if more than
more than two of us from this committee
are allowed to go talk to um somebody
from the hospital Association um and
have and have a private conversation I
mean cuz then we would we would have a
quarum and then you know then everything
would have to be
public I just and you know and you know
basically we we want to get the
information and get the and build the
relationships um but you know I and and
I I don't you know
I I'm not 100% sure that this setup is
is the best way to do that what about if
we sent an email to all of those I
listed tell them we're we're inviting
your input to have a seat at the table
we are tasked with finding solutions to
these things you are an important part
of this process please give input okay
maybe that would be a way to get it at
least on paper um and see what they say
and and it can kind of get everybody all
at once one email to all the whole list
of of all of them Real Estate
Association the New Hampshire Builders
Association the hospital Association the
developers um and New Hampshire Housing
Authority and say this is what we're
tasked with this impacts you we want
your
input that's I wonder um if we could set
up like a
longer Workshop to that effect um
working group I think a working group
but even to have um
you know if there's any
funding
um available to like hire up someone to
help facilitate this I mean it's a lot
for us volunteer
legislators
to um to organize an event that could be
really productive and bring everyone
together rather than you know just
having these meetings at this in the
lob um
um as an
idea um I'm I'm also wondering if there
would be a potential to set up some sort
of um well I'm going to call it a public
private partnership where um that we're
we're at the table but we're not
necessarily the
conveners yes that's sort of what I was
saying so is that possible so I think
um some housing related um conferences
and stuff like that that are especially
done by The Institute for politics or
something at St anom like they have
stuff um as far as like people from kind
of that all kind of come together on
specific day and talk about like what's
going on maybe they might be interested
in
doing something like that for on this
topic as far as that where they bring
all the people together and see like hey
the these are our problems these are our
Solutions what are your thoughts kind of
a thing um and then if we just
attended as and and hear their thoughts
then then that would be way that you
could
achieve that what you're think yeah yeah
the I believe the program that you're
talking about is the housing we need
project at the business and ethics
Institute which I think they've changed
their name but I've actually attended a
couple of those um yes me too yeah I but
yeah I was also when I looked up um the
woman who came from The Institute for
Disabilities at
UNH I looked I looked her up on their
website and they have a huge staff of
people um I mean that's a tremendous
amount of resources that we could
hopefully put to work on this problem
that you know that's there was that's
what they're paid to do could we not you
know bring them to the table to help
organize a symposium or maybe even the
New Hampshire Builders Association
they're always hosting things y I think
there's potential but we do need all
that input right that to we we just do I
mean on hindsight I do wish we had
appointed uh people with those
qualifications onto this
too y right but then it wouldn't be a
study committee it would be a
yeah but all right well you know well
just this we're imaginative and we are
we're talking we're thinking out loud
yeah I think that all of that sounds
like a a good idea um again you know we
uh I'm I'm trying to figure out how
because the institute on disabilities is
you know part of the I think they're
part of the University system
so can we um again you know would it be
a mandate if we put in our our
recommendations I I don't know well we
can't force people to I wouldn't yeah I
wouldn't want to and I wouldn't want you
know if they want to I wouldn't want to
try to force them to to take this on if
it's not something they want to do but I
think we need to investigate the
possibility of
having some organization that you know
is specific to um um helping people with
disabil ities to
um possibly be the convenor and help
bring everyone together in an
environment where um there is um is
parity between the people who are who
are interacting because I mean this is
this is not
a a convivial kind of setup here I I
also think that if you explain to these
entities
that we're going to do some legislation
and it's going to impact you and your
business we're offering you a seat at
the table to help with these Solutions I
think if they realize that that they're
going to be a willing
partner I think that's a great
idea okay all right so I um have been
writing furiously I probably should have
been typing this into the notes that I
had in there but I've been typing a lot
so yeah thank you so much
um so okay
so all right that that all okay is is
there anything else that um we would
like to
um like to include either as um findings
or recommendations I will be hoping I
will be this is due on the 1 of November
so I would think I've been thinking a
lot
about
um the situation again with people who
become
disabled um and they are in some of the
toughest situations
because in order to get help for their
serious medical
condition they're best off uh if and
they they can't work like they used to
work so they don't have Private health
insurance from their
job um if just on
Medicaid they can't go to just any
doctor because most private practices
don't take Medicaid they can go to the
ER and maybe a community health center
and that's about it so their best bet is
to get
on apply for disability then they get on
Medicare but it takes on average seven
years to get that disability approved so
you're stuck for seven years and but
then when you get it you can't
work so because most
people would probably prefer to work and
they make a little more money without
losing that health insurance which in
for people with
disabilities it's
Medicare um so they're they're really
stuck so it you know I don't think we
can ignore some of these big S systemic
problems that come from the way Social
Security and
Medicare um is mandated at the federal
level it has a tremendous impact on
people's
resources and you know and I think we've
heard so many situations
where if they have a disability and
they're lucky enough to get on Medicare
then they're sort of stuck in poverty
and they don't have enough money to pay
rent yes Senator I hear what you're
saying and concur by what we've heard in
this room but we have to remember one
thing as much as we would love to fix
all these problems this committee is
tasked with to study the impact of
housing crisis on people with
disabilities so we have to stay focused
on that even though we it'd be great to
fix everything because then we may not
get this fixed like I think we have to
really focus on exactly what we're task
with right but I think that could be
included as a
finding that contributes to why people
are in the situation they're in yeah as
a they they they have a disability and
they can't work or they lose their
health insurance and that is a
significant reason why they're in they
don't have enough money to pay market
rate
rent I yeah I I you know that was one of
the um things that I did want to include
that people who are disabled tend to be
very low income and can't compete in the
market rate housing market and and
um
yeah it should be included I just want
to make sure we have a light at the end
of this road here right right okay all
right
okay all right well that was that was a
lot I is there anything else that that
um okay so all right is there is there
anything else that people would like to
add um I was I'm going to stay here for
a little while um trying to sort through
all I see you guys have these beautiful
binders I have a bag full of
paper and I'm carrying around the
original original folder um which I need
to get
a b no that's okay no no thank you I
appreciate that um this is this is this
is an issue that goes back to I would
say sixth grade with
me I was always the paper stuffed in the
desk
anyway yeah so what what are what are
folks last words and then we can adjourn
paper well it was a pleasure in with you
guys like life yes thank you so much for
being here I really appreciated your uh
institutional knowledge and um um
helping me fig navigate jumping through
the Hoops in the right order which I you
know I did my best I probably came
participation last words I'm just
looking forward to continuing to uh work
together and get results it's all about
the results so just
um um for the process you know after we
reconvene um we would ask the speaker to
appoint someone else to like f it will
happen on
will we don't need we don't to make a
motion to uh to approve the uh the the
preliminary preliminary report as
discussed
um in this meeting because if so I will
make that motion okay I'll second it all
right all right thank you all in favor I
I guess I'm supposed to say without
objection right I me you can do either
and then but do we say that um subject
to um all of us reviewing it um
afterwards by email right yes to make
any minor Corrections or adjustments
yeah okay that that sounds terrific okay
I all right so I will get to work on
that and
um and I will send it out to you at ASAP
and um and uh it's it's been it's been
really good working with all of you I
really appreciate getting to know you
all better and um and
um learning motion to adjourn then um y
motion to adjourn so moved all
right um second
okay Al those oh without
objection okay okay all right we are